>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon.
It's wonderful to welcome
this really great gathering
through our Americas Award, which
we've been giving here since 1992.
So the Hispanic division
and the Center
for the Book have been
collaborated with the Consortium
of Latin American Studies
to give this really
wonderful award for children.
It is my great pleasure
to also announce
that this begins Hispanic Heritage
month at the Library of Congress.
And the Hispanic Heritage
calendar's outside,
so please pick it up
on your way out.
Because we have many wonderful
events for Hispanic Heritage.
And now it is my pleasure
to introduce Guy Lamolinara
from the Center for the
Book, who is our cosponsor.
[ Applause ]
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Thanks, Georgette,
and thanks to everybody here.
I'm really so pleased to be
representing the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress, which
is cosponsoring this wonderful event
with the Library's
Hispanic division.
And we've done that, as
Georgette said, for many years.
For those of you who don't know
about the Center for the Book,
we're a small public-private
partnership organization
within the Library of
Congress and our mission is
to promote books reading,
libraries and literacy.
And we do it here at the
National Center in Washington,
but we also have 52 affiliated
state centers for the Book.
We have one in DC and we also
have one in the US Virgin Islands.
So if you are interested
in what your local Center
for the Book is doing, you can just
Google Center for the Book and type
in the name of your state and
you'll see where your Center
for the Book is and the
programs that they do.
These programs promote your
state's literary heritage,
so they're really great
organizations.
Another thing the Center for the
Book does is we play a major role
in the National Book Festival.
We oversee the Library of Congress
literacy awards and also the Poetry
and Literature Center, which is
the home of the US poet laureate.
And I also want to thank
Georgette Dorn and the staff
of the Hispanic division for
including us in this great event,
as well as the Consortium
of Latin American Studies.
On the half of the Center for the
Book, I congratulate the authors
and illustrators for their
extraordinary achievements.
And thanks to Denis Woltering who
is the strategic program manager
of Tulane University Center
for Latin American Studies
who organized this event.
Please welcome Denis Woltering.
[ Applause ]
>> Denis Woltering: Thank you,
Guy, and thank you, Georgette
and the Hispanic Division
and thank you, Catalina,
and everyone that's helped
to sponsor this program
over the many years.
I'm very excited to be here,
2017 Americas Award Winners.
This year we had over
75 submissions.
And I'm very pleased over
the years, the submissions
of books titles has grown,
that's a really great thing.
We like to keep seeing
that number grow.
The committee this year had a really
wonderful time discussing the books.
It's been really interesting,
really fun being able to connect
with the committee this year
over Skype calls on three
to four different Sundays
during the springtime.
It takes up a lot of time
but a lot of fun time.
So I'd like to thank the committee
that's here and will be helping
to present at the program.
And you'll see their names here.
So I'd also like to
explain a little bit.
In your program here, you'll
see we've developed the program
over the many years.
And it talks a little bit
about class, the Consortium
of Latin American Studies Programs,
which this program is a product of.
It's one of our proudest -- our
projects that we are most proud of.
It's a project that CLASP has
sponsored since the early '90s.
And Julie Klein, the founder
of the award, is here.
We're very thankful that she
was able to join us here today.
And the Consortium of Latin
American Studies Program consists
of over 50 different centers
for Latin American studies
at different universities
across the country.
We all do different types
of outreach programming,
academic programs on Latin
America, the study of Latin America.
And this program has really
been a great way for us to reach
out into the community
using children's
and young adult literature.
This program especially would
like to thank the universities
of Florida International University,
Stanford University, Tulane,
the University of Florida,
University of New Mexico,
University of Utah, the University
of Wisconsin-Milwaukee,
and Vanderbilt.
I'd like to mention that my
colleague Colleen McCoy here
at Vanderbilt and myself
both coordinate this award.
I know it's a lot of different
people involved in this,
but we're very excited
and we're all very happy
for this year's award winners.
So I would like to
introduce our chair
of the committee, Ms. Denise Croker.
[ Applause ]
>> Denise Croker: Thank you, Denis.
I have the privilege of speaking
about the commended titles
and letting you know how
special and wonderful they are.
This year we have a number of books
that explore the hidden histories
of Latin America and their
influence here in the United States.
Once again, Margarita Engle brings
to life the little-known
historical events from Cuba
in her poetic novel, Lion Island,
about Chinese indentured servants
and others who escape
persecution to find refuge in Cuba
in the late 19th century.
They become warriors of words,
proving that violence is not
the only way to gain liberty.
The Princess and the
Warrior is another great work
by previous Americas
Award Winner and author
and illustrator, Duncan Tonatiuh.
The author draws from vibrant
cultural history and symbolism
from the Azteca, to retell a
romantic legend of two volcanoes,
evoking storytellers
from times long past.
Lowriders to the Center of the
Earth, written by Kathy Camper
and illustrated by Raul, III,
features Lupe, Elirio, and El Chavo,
who take a rollicking
ride to the underworld
as they search for their lost cat.
With puns, mariachi lyrics,
and lingo of the lowriders,
this is an unforgettable journey
to the realm of the Aztec past.
Another hidden history
is found in the School
That the Aztec Eagles Built, written
by Dorinda Makanaonalani Nicholson.
It's the inspirational World
War II story of Angel Bocanegra,
a dedicated teacher from
Mexico who volunteers
for the fighting pilots,
the Aztec Eagles.
His promise to return to his
community and build a school are
as inspirational as
the military missions.
Shame the Stars, by Guadalupe
Garcia McCall is a Romeo
and Juliet story set against the
backdrop of the border troubles
of 1915 between native Tejanos
and the white Texas Rangers.
With authentic newspaper
clippings and original poetry,
this is another book that shows the
power of speech to right injustice.
Juana and Lucas, written by Juana
Medina, is a more whimsical book.
An illustrated journey through
Bogota, Colombia, through the eyes
of quirky Juana and her
furry amigo, her dog Lucas.
Juana, too, learns
the power of words
and how languages open
doorways to other cultures.
Another common theme running through
these books is the power of art
and how it can represent the
history of people, which is found
in Rainbow Weaver, written
by Linda Elovitz Marshall
and illustrated by Elisa Chavarri.
With her Mayan weavings that are
made from repurposed plastic bags,
young Ixchel is able to pay for
her own books and her schooling,
which emphasizes Ixchel's
agency and her ingenuity.
In Radiant Child, author Javaka
Steptoe reveals the biography
of street artist Jean-Michel
Basquiat,
while showcasing his developing
work from childhood on,
making it accessible to
even the youngest reader.
Margarito's Forest, written
by Andy Carter and illustrated
by Allison Havens, tells us
the story of Don Margarito
and his lifelong commitment to
plant trees in his native Guatemala.
This trilingual book,
with English, Spanish,
and captions in the indigenous local
Mayan language, combines artwork
of a professional illustrator
and the children
of Don Margarito's village.
Another thing we see in our
committed titles is the power
of emotion and standing
up for yourself.
In the Memory of Light,
written by Francisco Stork,
main character Vicki learns to
trust in others, trust in herself,
and stand up for herself to her
family, who seem to only care
about career, success, and the
monetary side of the American dream.
Inspired by the author's
own experiences,
this young adult novel provides
a powerful message of acceptance
and empowerment for anyone
struggling with depression.
In Meg Medina's Burn Baby Burn, Nora
Lopez also faces problems at home
and violence in the streets of
summertime 1977 New York City,
when disco was king, temperatures
were hot, and frighteningly,
son of Sam was on the loose.
This novel confronts
problems of first
and second generation Cuban
immigrants, families members
who love each other but who do not
see the world from the same lens.
And finally, the theme of
immigration is the last theme
of these commended titles, next
seen in the children's book,
Somos como las nubes, We are Like
the Clouds, written by Jorge Argueta
and illustrated by Alphonso Verano.
The dreamy poetry and images in
this book contrasts beautifully
with the harsh realities
of migration
from Central America to the north.
The migrants become a family
of stars and move miraculously
across the miles like the
clouds, como las nubes.
And finally, we have Mama the
Alien, written by Rene Colato Lainez
and illustrated by Laura Lacamara.
When Sophia looks at her
mother's old drivers license,
she discovers that her
mother is an alien.
And she first imagines that her
mother must come from another planet
and that she's got alien friends
who will soon visit
her in a flying saucer.
This clever book compares or
clarifies the important topic
of immigration and the process
of becoming a US citizen.
In the author's note she
remarks, I want readers to know
that immigrants may be referred
to as aliens, but this only means
that they come from other countries.
We are all citizens
of the planet Earth.
And so we celebrate these titles
and we congratulate their
authors and illustrators.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Maria Sheldon: Good afternoon.
The cultural richness
in our country is based
on everyone's participation.
It's such an honor to invite a woman
that represents not only the culture
of the Caribbean but the elegant way
asking how she helps us understand
what it means to be
a global citizen.
Canada, the US, Middle
East, Trinidad, and Tobago.
She invite us all to reflect in the
richness of the Caribbean language
and implore us to open our
hearts as we create empathy
with a global citizenry
where we're all impacted.
Nadia Hohn, author
of Malaika's Costume,
it is such an honor to
have you right here.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nadia Hohn: [foreign
language] My hope is one day
that this book will
be in Spanish as well.
I close my eyes and dance.
I am a beautiful peacock.
Each feather shimmers green,
gold, turquoise, and brown.
Grandma say, girl, it is
definitely [inaudible].
I think I messed that up.
Trying to do it from memory.
It's like grandma say, girl,
I think you is definitely
my granddaughter for true.
So I want to start first by thanking
the grandmothers, the mothers,
the fathers, the grandfathers
in my family,
the ancestors who made the
biggest migration of all.
Of course, there's the
trans-Atlantic slave trade centuries
ago and over the centuries.
And recently in the past century,
having gone from Jamaica to Panama
to help construct the canal,
from Jamaica to Cuba to work
in sugarcane, to go to UK,
to go to the United States,
like my grandfathers did, and my
great uncle and my grandmothers,
and also to Canada where I was born.
So I want to thank all of them
because that I found was part
of the inspiration for this story.
So the story takes
place in the Caribbean.
Malaika is living with her grandma,
and mom has left to go to Canada
to work and send money back
home to support the family.
So it's also carnival time and the
first carnival since mom has gone.
So now Malaika's left with waiting
for this money that's supposed
to come for the costume,
and it doesn't come.
So what is she going to do?
And that's what this story is about.
But it's also about a
lot of other things too.
And as I mentioned, migration
is a theme that runs through it.
I also want to say thank you but
make mention of the inspiration
which is Trinidad's carnival.
The carnival in Trinidad
is quite well known.
And there are Caribbean
carnivals all
over the actual Caribbean
but also the diaspora.
So there is one here.
There's one in Toronto.
And this is the kind of
festive atmosphere that I grew
up with knowing going to
the carnival each year.
So actually there's a woman
at the back I have to mention,
because she's actually
from Trinidad.
And I saw her on the plane.
And then I saw her here.
So I said, you need to come.
So she's the representative
from Trinidad.
So thank you to Trinidad and to the
beautiful culture that's been given
to us.
And just understand that when
people leave their countries behind,
they don't leave everything behind,
the bring their cultures with them.
So I also want to thank and dedicate
this book as I did in the story
to the students I taught at the
Afrocentric Alternative School.
It's the first publicly-funded
school,
Afrocentric school, in Canada.
So I wrote the story thinking
of ways that I can make sure
that books look like
the kids that I teach.
And I actually wrote this
for a class assignment.
So it took about six years for it
to actually become a physical book.
So it gives me great pleasure
to have it here in my hands.
And I also want to
thank the Consortium
for Latin American Studies Programs.
Thank you for thinking
of the Caribbean as well.
And also our stories
are very similar.
We have a common thread of having
similar histories of colonization
and slavery and imperialism
and that sort of thing.
And how those have played
out in different ways
in the global economy, as the
economies of these regions
and how they actually come down
to people making very personal
and heartbreaking decisions.
So I just want to close with this.
I close my eyes and I am in front
of you at the Library of Congress
in Washington, DC, presenting
and also accepting an
honor for this book.
And at the start of this year --
I like to do visioning boards.
I don't know if you do that.
But I just like to visualize and
put a picture to the things I want.
And two of the things that stand
out to me, I wanted to come
to Washington, DC,
Baltimore, Philly.
I put them all together.
So I'm going to Philly tomorrow --
or sorry, Baltimore tomorrow
and Philly in October.
So that's coming up.
But I also wanted to win an award.
And I'm so glad it's this
award because the theme
of migration is so important.
We've all migrated if not ourselves,
our parents or people before us.
And you think about the things
we brought to this country.
I have some cousins here
who also they live here,
the US is their home.
So I want to just thank you for
taking the time to acknowledge this.
And thank you so much
for being here.
And thank you for this honor.
[ Applause ]
>> Paula Mason: Thank you.
Hello, my name is Paula Mason,
and I'm a public librarian
in the Milwaukee area.
And I'm on the selection committee.
It is with great honor that I
introduce author Reyna Grande
and her outstanding title,
The Distance Between Us,
adapted for young readers
and based off
of her 2012 award-winning memoir.
Reyna provides readers
with an intimate look
at the multifaceted effect
that modern-day immigration
has on young people.
We first step into her
shoes as a child left behind
with her grandparents in
her hometown in Mexico.
We feel the emotional impact that
this has on Reyna and her siblings,
who dream of reuniting with
her parents, and in particular,
with the father that she knows only
as the man behind the
glass of a picture frame.
Later, she undergoes the fraught
experience of crossing the border
without documents into a land
that offers promise of dreams
to be realized but not without
substantial strife and struggles.
Throughout all of this,
Reyna provides young readers
with a compelling and
bracingly honest narrative
as she forges her own identity
and strives towards her
academic and personal goals.
While for some her book
provides an important look
into an experience
distinct from their own,
for so many other readers,
aspects of this timely
memoir will resonate deeply
with their own first-hand experience
of immigration and their families.
Thank you so much, Reyna, for your
wonderful gift you've given us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Reyna Grande: Hello, everyone.
It's great to be here
with you today.
Thank you so much for this honor.
And I would like to dedicate
this recognition to the Dreamers.
Because these are child immigrants
who came to America the way I did.
And my story is so
similar to theirs.
With the difference that
I was very fortunate
to be given the opportunity
to legalize my status.
And that is something that
I'm really fighting for them
to also have that same opportunity.
So I want to dedicate
this recognition to them.
Because they, like me, have
also had a lot of trauma.
They've had a lot of heartbreak .
And they took so many risks
and made so many sacrifices
to be here in this country.
And they continue to give their best
to make this country
a great place to live.
As you heard, my book is about
the often not acknowledged effect
of immigration, which is the
disintegration of a family.
And that is the book
that I wanted to write
about how immigration
impacts not just the parents,
not just the children,
but the entire family.
And everything that happens
affects the families.
But also there's an inheritance
of trauma that gets passed
down to the next generation.
And that is something that I myself
am struggling with as a parent is,
how do I not pass on my
trauma to my children?
And I am very grateful actually
for everything that I went through,
even though I'm still suffering
from all of those things.
Because now as a parent,
when I look back on my life,
I'm very grateful that, you
know, I was the one who went
through family separation.
I was the one who had to
watch my father walk away,
my mother walk away.
I was the one who risked
my life to cross the border
so that my own children
never have to do that.
And now I'm able to give my children
something that I didn't have,
which is a parent that
stays with them.
And to me, that is what
makes it all worth it.
And that's why when I look back
on my life, I am very grateful.
Because I feel that, you know,
it's worth what I went through,
so that my children get a shot at
the American dream without the pain
that I went through to
have that same opportunity.
So I want to thank everyone
for recognizing these stories
of immigrants who contribute
so much to this country.
And it's important for us
to acknowledge everything
that we have done to make
this country what it is,
which is a really wonderful
country where opportunities exist.
And I want to make sure that
we all continue to fight
to make this a country
where everyone is made
to feel that they belong.
And where everyone is made
to feel that they are enough.
Because we are enough.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> David Campos: Hello,
my name is David Campos,
and I am the newest member
on the award committee.
When I was first asked to
participate, I was pretty excited,
because I was a former
second-grade teacher.
And so I love children's
books, as you can imagine.
And so from September up till
about December, I was so excited
because I would see the mail
truck, and it's like, oh,
I know I'm getting something.
Or I'd come home and there would
be a package on my front door.
Ada's Violin, which is the award
winner today, came in a big box,
and I'm not sure why,
but it was in a big box
with lots of stuffing in it.
And as I opened it, I
was immediately drawn
to the absolutely beautiful colors.
They just pulled me in.
And I did what every good
second-grade teacher would do,
they do a book walk.
So I did a book walk through it.
And I just couldn't wait
to start reading the story.
And it was very meaningful to me.
I just absolutely fell
in love with the story .
So without further ado, I'm
going to present two awards.
One is to the author, Susan Hood.
And if you'll please come on up.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
And I'd like to go ahead and
present the illustrated award
as well, Susan -- excuse me.
Sally Wern Comport.
[ Applause ]
>> I do want to take a
moment actually and present
to you something that's been a
tradition through the Americas Award
that Julie Klein started.
And we give a weaving
that's been woven
and it represents your
weaving of stories.
So this is direct from our
kachacha [phonetic] language scholar
from Guatemala.
>> Susan Hood: Thank you so much.
Okay, [foreign language] to
the awards committee, CLASP,
and the Library of Congress
for recognizing Ada's Violin,
for this wonderful award, along
with Alexandra Diaz's The Only Road.
And congratulations to
all the other honorees.
I know much of your work and it's
a joy to be with you here today.
I'd love to tell you that I
discovered the recycled orchestra
of Paraguay, but that
would be fake news.
All the credit goes to my Simon &
Schuster editor, Christian Tremor,
who caught the 60 Minutes news
report about the orchestra
and thought it might
make a good picture book.
He asked if it held any interest.
Did it. I never followed the old
adage, to write what you know.
I write about what surprises me,
what I want to know more about.
Well, this story didn't surprise me,
it dazzled me, knocked
me for a loop.
I was all in.
I'm so grateful to Christian,
my agent, Brenda Bowen,
and Simon & Schuster for the
opportunity to share Ada's story
with young readers
and for pairing me
up with my spectacular
illustrator, Sally.
Library, school, journal, culture,
artwork for the book's transcendence
and nothing short of
brilliant, and I heartily agree.
When I thought about
how to tell this story,
I decided there were two ways to do
it: the easy way and the hard way.
Guess which way I chose?
The easy way would've been to
read the many, many press reports
about the orchestra for background
information, make up a kid,
and write a fictional book
based on a true story.
But for me, that approach would
diminish the story's power.
If written as fiction, readers would
likely dismiss it as unbelievable.
Would you believe that anyone could
make a violin from a baking pan,
a stick of lumber, and a fork?
Or -- well, there was a picture
of a clarinet that was made
out of drainpipes,
buttons, and house keys.
I think we've all improvised
kitchen sink bands,
but you can't play
Beethoven on them.
The orchestra plays Beethoven,
Bach, Mozart, and the Beatles
so beautifully, they're in demand
all over the globe and play
for world leaders,
including the Pope.
You just can't make this stuff up.
So the orchestra's story is
astounding because it's all true.
So for me, it had to be nonfiction.
I had to find a way to reach
kids in Paraguay and get them
to tell their story
in their own words.
Well, what's so hard about that?
I couldn't afford to
travel to Paraguay.
I'm an author.
And remember, these kids
live on the landfill.
So there's no postal service,
almost no electricity.
I had no idea if anyone
had a telephone
or access to email or Skype.
The biggest problem for me was that
I don't speak Spanish and no one
in the orchestra speaks English.
After selling my editor on a
nonfiction approach, I thought, oh,
boy, Susan, what have
you gotten yourself into?
As I tell kids on school visits,
don't be afraid to ask for help.
My first step was to
hire a translator.
And I'd like to give a shout
out to Shelley McConnell who's a
Connecticut teacher from Mexico.
I could not have written
this book without her.
My second step was to reach out
to the producers of 60 Minutes,
who were delighted with the
idea of a possible picture book.
They put me in touch
with Favio Chavez,
the conductor of the orchestra.
And it turned out that he did
have access to email and Skype.
So I did several rounds
of interviews with him
and later with Ada online.
It was quite a process.
Writing the questions.
Translating them.
Waiting for a window when the
orchestra wasn't on tour in Mexico
or Germany or Colombia or Japan.
It was often weeks and sometimes
months before I would hear back.
And then of course, their
answers had to be translated back
into English for me, and then
that generated new questions.
So we'd have to start the whole
long process all over again.
But it was worth the wait.
Ada told me that she thinks of each
garbage truck as a box of surprises.
That statement and the optimism
behind it knocked me out.
Digging into this story was like
unearthing my own box of surprises.
It was truly life-changing.
I try not to take things for
granted, but let's face it,
I have clean running water and
electricity at the flick of a wrist.
There's green grass outside my door.
My family and I don't think twice
about phone service, air-condition,
transportation, police,
firefighters,
public schools, or
garbage collection.
Or something as simple and
life-changing as shoes.
Ada's world is far
from an isolated case.
People live in garbage dumps all
over the world: Mexico, India,
Philippines, and on and on.
Last May, more than 100 people were
killed on a landfill in Ethiopia
when their homes were buried
by an avalanche of trash.
In the middle of my interviews with
Ada, disaster struck there too.
The river that runs through the town
flooded causing hundreds of families
to evacuate their tin shacks.
What had been a mountain of trash
became a sea of toxic garbage.
And yet despite all of this, Ada
and her friends remain hopeful,
resilient, and dedicated to
making music for the world.
At a time when the national
endowment for the arts is
under siege in our
country, Ada's story sings
of the lifesaving power of the arts.
Degas once said, art is not what you
see but what you make others see.
And it's clear that music made these
aimless forsaken kids something
to focus on, something to strive
towards, and something to hope for.
For many it was the only
beauty in their lives.
They learned how to
play their instruments.
And they learned a few other
things as well: focus, discipline,
dedication, respect for
themselves and for each other.
And music is literally helping
them rebuild their lives
and their community.
Profits from their concerts and
proceeds from this book go back
to Paraguay where the
families use the money
to build brick houses
out of the flood zone.
Ada was right, there
was indeed a box
of surprises waiting
in the landfill.
Buried in the trash was music.
And buried in these kids was
something to be proud of.
Gracias.
[ Applause ]
>> Sally Wern Comport: I'm going to
have to ask for assistance here to.
I am not a wordsmith, I'm an artist.
I'm the illustrator
for Ada's Violin.
And so I don't have a lovely
written talk for you, because,
like I said, I'm about pictures.
So I need to show you slides.
I can tell you this.
Simon & Schuster called me and said,
are you interested in
illustrating a book?
And we want to send you
a trailer about this book
that will be written,
is yet to be complete.
I didn't have a manuscript but I
had about a three-minute trailer
that had me weeping from the start.
The music was so beautiful.
The story, while limited and
abbreviated, was so moving
and so positive in terms
of the impact of what music
and a teacher brought to these
students that were living on a dump.
So what you do when you're
illustrating is you try
to bring yourself to that space.
Well, I waited for the story
after I said yes immediately,
and I waited for the manuscript.
And then I got Susan's manuscript.
And what can I say?
To be introduced through the lens
of Ada was the most amazing way
to take this story and feel
as though you could try
in the best way possible
to be sitting there
with them, to be with them.
So I'm going to take you
just plainly to the studio.
So there's a studio space,
and this is where it begins.
In Annapolis, just shy of here,
which means I was not familiar
with South America either.
So it's how do you feel?
What these people feel, it is
important to immerse yourself in.
There's more studio.
So you can see, it's kind of a mess.
So I had a little bit of
a dump site in my studio.
But it also is where
the creative comes from.
So the inspiration comes from
thinking about the materials
that might be around, thinking
about the color, the temperature,
the smell, all of that, and
immersing yourself in it.
I went to the Spanish grocery store
in my community, took photographs
of all the things, to try
to create a garbage dump
that we could just slightly
think was beautiful.
Because there was nothing beautiful
about the photographs
that came from this.
And try to find the art, the color,
the things that represent what
this culture might have seen,
whether it be labels or color or --
and then to see the
instruments themselves,
amazing pieces, works of art.
And the inspiration for the images
is completely because of the story,
because of the sculptures that were
made, crafted by one craftsman,
a carpenter in the village.
And when you see where he lives and
how inspiring his story alone was,
it helps you to see the ripples in
the pond that happen from an idea.
And hopefully it translates
to the world that way.
That was what was apparent
in the film.
When I do a book, I will choreograph
it throughout in the palette,
so that when you look at the
thumbnails of the first sketches
that were done for this book,
you want to walk through it
as if you're walking
through the story and come
out with the inspirational
feeling that I had
when I read Susan's
incredible manuscript.
And it starts with more of the
paper, more of the collaging.
It inspired all of the
images, was the story itself.
Every book that's done
is done hopefully
from my studio inspired
by what I'm looking at.
So I would not draw the same
book that I was drawing for this
if it was another author
or another story.
But I wanted you to feel
heat when you looked
at these kids practicing outside.
And I wanted you to
feel their emotion
when they thought about
getting on stage.
So I grabbed the nearest studio
assistant I had and said, Lindsay,
you're very, very afraid.
And here my two Arian and
Lindsay, you're really thrilled
to be performing in a world
stage with this amazing band.
So hopefully that is coming
from the story in the images.
I can barely do the
inspirational story any justice.
But I'm very grateful for this
honor and for this organization
and what you bring to the world.
So thank you for the
honor and the invitation.
[ Applause ]
>> Emily Chavez: Good afternoon.
Very afraid of dropping
-- okay, now it's safe.
It is an honor to present this
Americas Award to Alexandra Diaz
for The Only Road,
this book right here.
I'm Emily Chavez, a member
of the review committee,
and I am the outreach coordinator
for the UNC Duke Consortium
and Latin American
and Caribbean Studies.
Thank you.
And I'm a former English teacher,
high school English teacher.
So this book was just a book that
I had the pleasure of reading.
After I read it, I really
couldn't stop talking about it
or telling everyone I knew about it.
It is a powerful portrayal of why
young people, so many young people,
have traveled to this country alone
from their countries of origin
to this one, and how they do so.
I see this as an empathy-building
novel.
Jaime and Hella are the main
characters and they leave Guatemala
to travel to Mexico, meeting
friends and others along the way.
They are teenagers and they are
cousins who wrestle with exhaustion,
grief, hunger, and longing
throughout their journey.
Jaime and Hella are also
playful, hopeful, curious.
And the novel does not shy away
from the many threats and injustices
of the migration journey
from Guatemala,
through Mexico, to
the United States.
Yet, Alexandra Diaz has
written it in such a way
that makes it appropriate for middle
school and high school readers.
Many communities and schools
across the US have seen
and experienced the change in
recent years, more kids coming
from Guatemala, El
Salvador, and Honduras.
Many arriving as unaccompanied
minors who may
or may not be reuniting with
families here that they know.
At the peak of this
migration pattern,
27,000 unaccompanied minors arrived
from Central America
to the US in June 2014.
This book is timely.
It's needed.
And an awesome resource for so
many students, both those who want
to learn more about Latin
American youth migrating to the US,
as well as young Latin
American immigrants who want
to see themselves in the pages
of the books that they read.
This is a book about
choices and the lack thereof.
This is a book about survival.
This is a book about connection.
So I'm very happy to
introduce Alexandra Diaz,
the author of The Only Road.
[ Applause ]
>> I also want to give you
a weaving from Guatemala.
So thank you so much.
>> Fantastic.
>> Alexandra Diaz: [inaudible]
I just forgot to print it,
so I needed my notes
from my computer.
I'm going to put this on now.
I don't know how to wear it,
but I'm like feeling very loved.
Thank you.
So I want to say thank you so much
for the opportunity to be here.
I'm Alexandra Diaz, the
author of The Only Road.
People have asked me if I've
been to Washington, DC before
and if I've been to the
Library of Congress.
And I always feel like
saying, yes, I have.
But I actually do not remember
being in the Library of Congress.
So I feel it was one of those things
that happened as a teenager that,
you know, this is this,
this is that,
and I didn't pay attention enough.
Which is a shame.
But, you know, at the same time,
it means that my opportunity
to be here is that
much more memorable.
I took the tour and I could just see
and feel all the books
that were here.
And to be a part of that,
it's this feeling like,
can life even got any better?
Because it's a huge honor.
And I have read the works of, you
know, my fellow award winners,
and I keep thinking, they
must've made a mistake
because their books are so fabulous
and so wonderful, why am I here.
So I thank CLASP for thinking of me.
I thank Simon & Schuster for
sending the book, for encouraging me
to write it, everyone
who is involved.
I'm sure I'm going to forget
somebody and so I'll stop there
and just say, everyone is thanked.
This book, The Only Road,
is a very timely book
with a personal connection.
I am the daughter of Cuban refugees.
And I grew up hearing stories about
Cuba and what it was like not to --
not only to live there
but also to leave there.
Leaving your family, your
friends, your home, and not knowing
if you could ever go back.
So both of my parents
left as teenagers.
They left with nothing but $5
and two changes of clothes.
They were not allowed
to take anything else.
Those who were caught smuggling
additional items were imprisoned.
And people who spoke against
the government were executed,
sometimes even publicly.
So I grew up with these
stories, hearing about what it's
like to leave your family, leave
your home, and leave your country,
because it's the only way that
you have a chance of surviving.
When the opportunity came to write
this modern-day immigration novel,
I immediately jumped at the chance.
I'm like [foreign language]
I have to write this.
Because it's what my
parents went through.
It's what so many children
are going through right now.
And you ask yourself, well,
why are they doing this?
You know, why are you putting
yourself in such a danger?
And the thing is that
there is no other choice.
People are doing this because
there is no other option.
I did take the easy route and made
a fictional story with this book.
But still wanted to base it
on real events, real people,
and real things that are going on.
I wrote this book two years ago.
And at the time, immigration
was a very hot topic.
I had no idea that it would
become so much more controversial
and so much more of a hot topic
given the political situation today.
But I also wanted to bring -- so
not only did I want to have a novel
that shared what was realistically
happening, but I also wanted
to bring a novel of hope.
So spoiler alert.
They live.
And you know, there are
a lot of opportunities.
A lot of bad things can happen,
but there are still a lot
of opportunities and a lot
of reasons to help them
to strive and want to continue.
And I truly believe that
if you don't have hope,
you don't really have a life.
So even when things get really
bad and you're struggling
and you don't know how you're going
to survive, it's holding on to
that hope and holding
on to that feeling
that maybe things will change,
maybe things will be better.
Maybe you have to make decisions
that you may not have
wanted to make.
But you know, it is for the better.
I mean, like Reyna was saying,
that she was so glad she made
that journey because now she
has that hope for her children.
Her children don't have
to go through that.
So I did want to make sure
my novel was realistic
but still kept that
light of a promise.
So even when you have no choice,
there is always a different path.
So again, thank you so much
for allowing me to be here.
I am just so honored.
And my mom is not here.
I love my mommy.
And she was the one who
always encouraged me
to write and keep writing.
She is my biggest fan and I
love her to bits because of it.
So I certainly wouldn't have been
able to be here if it hadn't been
for her and her strength and her
unconditional love of what I wanted
to do, and never once telling
me I had to get a real job.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen McCoy: Thank
you so much, Alexandra.
Well said.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you to the Library of
Congress once again and all
of our supporters, our review
committee members, and of course,
our authors and illustrators.
At this time we'd like to invite you
to join us for a reception and also
to meet and greet and maybe get
a book signed with our authors
and illustrator here today.
Reyna, Nadia, and Alexandra will be
at the table right here to the back.
And then just through this
doorway, will be Sally and Susan.
Susan will be ducking out
shortly to catch a train.
So if you have to go chat with her,
I recommend you visit her first.
Thank you all again and
hope to see you next year.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.